richard joins us from Scottsdale Arizona
to start this hour off hey Richard how
are you I'm better than you deserve babe
[Music]
how can I help
okay so my mother passed away a few
months ago and there was some funds left
that were distributed between my
siblings and myself I received over
18,000 last week which I took your
advice and paid off almost all of my
debt
good one credit card last 27 stands 39
cents I just received my today my stock
is first meant that can I say the name
of the company sure Disney you got
Disney stock okay I got Disney stock and
uh 164 shares and it straighten it 100
bucks a share you know 99 105 somewhere
in there so my intention is to transfer
that money from the Disney to my
brokerage account okay I also have a
Roth IRA and those funds are not very
good you know I put some money in there
a few years ago and it's all in one
stock which is taking a nosedive so I'm
in a negative there I'm not too worried
about it I'm considering I'd have to
sell off like 30 shares and get myself
completely out of debt and that's going
to take me like I don't know a week or
so to do that and then I can call you up
and scream so the question is what
should I do
with the remainder of that asset mm-hm
which would be like hard 130 shares on a
30 something church well you're right I
would become debt-free and I'd probably
cash out enough more to make sure
had my emergency fund in place you
probably heard me talk about the baby
steps then so that gets you through baby
step three if you've got a fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses do you have any money in
savings that's not in brokerage no okay
then once I've done that then we're up
to baby step 4 which is investing and it
sounds like you've got some work to do
there you've got an underperforming IRA
that's invested in something that's not
doing well and you've got some single
stock left over at this point from
Disney and whatever is in that brokerage
account I do not personally invest in
single stocks I know a lot about it and
I own a lot of stock through mutual
funds but I millions of dollars worth
but I don't yeah I don't own a single
single stock because I don't like the
risk associated with it it's very very
difficult to make money playing single
stocks on your own account like
virtually impossible now give me an
example I'm taking I'm taking it that
you would invest I would take care I
would get out of the single spark
yeah I would cash it out and I'd put it
in mutual funds and I and there'll be no
taxes on it because your basis in it is
what it's worth when you inherited it
which was this week so you're fine
and I would cash out by the way I would
roll that single stock that's
underperforming in an IRA how or if you
get a single stock in an IRA anyway but
if you did that and it's underperforming
then get out of that get that inside
that IRA into some good mutual funds and
steadily constantly consistently
investing in good growth stock mutual
funds in and outside of your retirement
accounts that are available there's a
high correlation to that and people that
make it to millionaire status and so
it's just real simple it's real boring
and again I don't play single stocks
that's no knock on Disney I didn't it
doesn't matter who you said they if it
was Apple which is probably one of the
best performers out there I suppose it's
done extremely well I would still tell
you to get out of it I cause it's what I
would do if I woke up in your shoes and
and I can I know I would do that because
I don't buy single stocks and where I
to inherit some would immediately cash
them and roll them into mutual funds
probably within a few days of having
gotten them and it's that simple so
here's the thing people play single
stocks with their fishing buddies and
their golfing buddies and they've all
got a fishing story in a golfing story
in a stock story and they're all lies
they tell the story of the one time that
they hit a good shot right down the
fairway they tell the story the one time
they caught a big fish and they tell the
story the one time they picked the
winner on the single stocks most people
never pick winners on a single stocks
and even if you use a broker if the your
broker was too dadgum smart then he
picked single stock winners he'd be
running a five billion dollar mutual
fund instead of being your broker think
that through that I mean what is it what
is a mutual fund manager except a very
large broker they have a whole research
team that picks single stocks they're
gonna pick better stocks than your
fishing buddy and your golfing buddy and
this is how people buy single stocks
it's like the biggest lie on the planet
Wall Street Journal has done several
pieces of research and published several
pieces of research the average person
buying and selling single stocks
averages about a seven percent rate of
return on their brokerage account using
their broker and their best idea from
their golfing buddy and something they
read somewhere and they watched the HBO
movie billions and thought they were
that guy our series or whatever that
thing is called and you're just not
that's all fiction on average they make
seven percent rate of return by the way
the S&P 500 if you had just dumped it
into that would have paid you between
eleven and twelve in the last 60 to 70
years Wall Street Journal did a funny
one several years ago many many many
years ago I used to use it in the old
Financial Peace University lessons they
put all the stocks on the stock market
the New York Stock Exchange on the wall
and they blindfolded a monkey and gave
him darts and he picked out any threw
darts and hit the stocks on the wall and
then they got brokers to come in and
tell the brokers that he could pick any
stock anywhere on the
all and see if they can beat the
blindfolded monkey eight out of ten
times the blindfolded monkey beat the
brokers now the little piece of funny
research is rigged actually because when
you are limited to picking only one
stock and you can get no diversification
at all you're fried the chances are less
than 50/50 that you're going to make
money on that in a given period of time
so it was really a rigged deal to
illustrate the point that single stocks
are not a good play for the typical
small investor but it does make the
point just the same
you can't beat a blindfolded monkey come
on really pretty bad so I can't buy
though I beat a blindfolded monkey and I
know a lot about this all the licenses
all the letters after my name all the
degrees all that crap right and I'm not
gonna take on the blindfolded monkey
because the game is rigged in the regard
of when you pick one stock it's
difficult to beat a diversified
portfolio nyeeeeehhh statistically
impossible to beat a diversified
portfolio so it's a simple thing what
makes you the most money with the least
risk that simple equation this is the
Dave Ramsey chef
[Music]